the mother who remains anonymous had
healthy ovaries but was born without a
womb it's a condition affecting roughly
one in four thousand five hundred women
surgeons at gothenburg university
hospital implanted her with a uterus
donated by a 61 year old family friend a
year later the woman became pregnant by
her husband via in vitro fertilization I
think it can have major impact a huge
impact because it actually gives hope
and it gives hope to those women and and
men also of course that thought they
would never have a child surgeons at
gothenburg university hospital decided
to perform a caesarean section two weeks
early after the mother developed high
blood pressure and the baby showed signs
of stress it was only when the healthy
boy began to cry that the team realized
that more than 15 years of research had
finally paid off well of course that was
a fantastic happiness among me and the
whole team but in the same time it was a
little unreal Association also because
we I mean we really couldn't believe
that we had reached his moment professor
brands drums team has performed seven
successful uterus transplants some for
women who had lost their own room to
cancer two of the women are reportedly
already six months pregnant however
although the procedure is being hailed
as a major medical breakthrough
gynecological specialists cautioned that
it is far from certain if the expensive
and risky procedure will become more
common